the Joe Rogan experience to my Instagram
picture burped today that's good he
looks [ __ ] great it looks really good
legit yeah you know Whitney was like
what did scram filters this like unless
he's doing with one some of my wife's
friends do huh
my wife's friends are [ __ ] there
they're cartoonists you that where
they're able to like taking pictures
they're cartoonists yeah
these [ __ ] run filters on these
pictures and they shrink their legs down
right and they [ __ ] with their friends
like they make their friends but a
little smaller or their arms a little
bigger
that's so diabolical and do weird things
that you ever think that you can either
make their friends changed they
definitely do that to each other they
don't and they call each other up hey
take this one down I don't like how many
ways looks you look great oh you look
amazing
that bird picture by the way the
lighting is pretty [ __ ] good I'm not
gonna go back there's almost nothing you
could do about the side knob but that
light save it look at his side these
sides wait that looks a little
manipulated they're not manipulated it's
not manipulated trust me Burt is not
that guy he's not smart enough to do
that no no no no that's not what I'm
saying he's not a liar like look Burt
would not do that that's what he looks
like he's been [ __ ] working out hard
he's down to like 225 look at it Ari
I wrote there he's raising his arms and
sucking news building tone to post an
interaction side shot of him on stage
all right such a hater well they've got
some beef now after the dose of neurosis
yeah well Burt should have beat not Ari
yeah are we [ __ ] dosed him are you
serious man that it didn't land as well
the well he is what the way he wanted
like our he's upset that Burt didn't
like laugh it off and have fun of it who
the [ __ ] laughs off getting dosed with
trust me dude I [ __ ] know but dose me
would be [ __ ] I think they should
fight it out let him [ __ ] slug it out
a little while I think Burt wants to
[ __ ] kill him for that who'd you win
who'd win that fight a fun fight to
watch cuz early Hurley re squirrelly
he's got that like he's like lanky and
long and [ __ ] he could put up a good
fight Burt's got the bird scout probably
the first guy probably you know there
may be a reach on him I don't how much
taller he is well Ari is very tall he's
tall he's
6:3 Jitsu background to a little bit
right a little a little bit a little bit
a little bit
I bought him a year he probably went he
went until he got staff and that was
about basically the end of its when most
people would quit he got a bad staph
infection on his knee man it was
horrible swole up like he was walking
with a limp that she can kill you oh
yeah he didn't even know he had he
thought it was a mosquito a spider bite
and he just let it go for we were
playing pool and he was walking around
with a limp I'm like what's wrong with
your leg and he goes I got a spider bite
and you know obviously I've done jujitsu
forever and I know that sometimes people
think it's a spider bite and staff says
let me see he pulls his knee up I go
dude and I unscrew my pool cue I go go
to the emergency room right now I go you
have a bad staph infection yeah he
thought I was [ __ ] with them he's
like he's serious I'm like I am dead
serious this can kill you I'm not
kidding his [ __ ] knee was all swollen
yeah get up like a real clear staph
infection I'm like dude you got I'm
telling I'm not a doctor but that is
[ __ ] staff and then he was angry and
he had a really good point
he's like why don't they have signs in
the gym yeah like you take jiu-jitsu and
it's up to everybody to tell you what
staff is
[Applause]